[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MASHROOF HOSSAIN: So thank you
very much for the opportunity
of the presentation.
So today, I will be presenting
about the Ganges water
conflicts between India and
Bangladesh, which is actually
one of the major
bone of contents
that's happening between the
two neighboring countries.
So I will be speaking about--
it is basically-- it
follows three flows.
The first part, will
speak about from where
the problem originated.
And the second part
will say that--
what is the present condition.
And the third part
will be steps,
which I think will be the most
relevant part for our class.
That is the water diplomacy
part on how we can actually
approach that problem, and how
we can try to find a solution.
So let me go to the next slide.
So I would be putting a
little bit of disclaimer.
Some part of my
discussion might not
match with Bangladesh
government's official view.
So I would-- this is important
because of years of training--
because I am not an academic--
because of years of
training, two things happen.
The first one is
subconsciously--
and I have found it even when
I've taken classes in Japan
or in the US--
that's automatically, I
actually reflect the views
of a typical
Bangladeshi bureaucrat,
the particular
government's point of view.
It is very-- I had to
train myself to stay away
from that view, and try to match
with the academic standard,
and come up with as much as
objective point of view as
possible.
So here, I would try
deliberately, I mean,
not to match the
typical stuff that
is said by the
Bangladesh government,
or any government too per se.
So that is one thing.
And the second part is
the political history.
Because although
it's a river treaty,
but it is very sensitive both
for Bangladesh and India.
And the political history
between Bangladesh and India
has a influence in
this whole discussion.
So knowingly or
unknowingly, sometimes
that political history will
visit us in my presentation.
So with these two disclaimers,
I'll start my presentation.
So first, a little bit
of history and geography.
So you all know about
the Indian subcontinent,
that there are many countries.
It was basically under the
British rule for 200 years.
And before that, it was 600
years under the Mughals,
or the Muslims.
So before 1947, the leftmost,
the huge map that you
see total blue, this
is the situation
of Indian subcontinent.
And in 1947, right after
the Second World War,
the Indian subcontinent
was divided into two.
And that is after the
partition in 1947,
you can see the green part
still stays the India,
the present day India.
And the orange part, a
deep orange part, that is--
on the upper side,
it's West Pakistan.
And on the lower side,
this small country,
it's East Pakistan, which is
the modern-day Bangladesh.
So in 1971, we had a war against
the western part of Pakistan.
It was actually very natural.
You see that there
is almost 2,000 miles
gap between the two parts.
So it was obvious
for many reasons.
So in 1971, this first
one single country that
is India, second, India and
Pakistan, and after '71,
it became three countries.
That is India, Pakistan,
and Bangladesh.
So this is the case.
And here, I'm bringing
this little bit of history
to explain the relationship
dynamics of Bangladesh
and India.
Because without bringing
the relationship dynamics
between Bangladesh and
India, it is kind of
tough to understand
that how and why
this treaty is so sensitive.
So here, we can see that in 16
December, 1971, you can see,
this is the surrender ceremony.
This is the surrender ceremony
of the occupying force in 16
December.
And on the left side,
3 million people,
that is the official
number Bangladesh claims.
It is disputed.
But this is the official
number that it was killed.
So there was-- we
say that there has
been genocide and murders, which
happens almost in all the wars.
So this is the
surrender ceremony.
And there is an interesting
fact, you will see,
that in the left side, someone
who is signing for Bangladesh,
this is an Indian general,
General Jagjit Singh Aurora.
So you can understand
the historical connection
between India and Bangladesh.
It's very deep.
And it used to be--
during the liberation war, India
directly helped us militarily.
And later, after the
independence, which--
both the parties considered
that both India and Bangladesh
would be very friendly.
But after the independence,
that actually changed.
And major anti-Indian sentiment
has been present there.
And one of the
reasons this happened
is the Farakka Dam, which
has created serious trouble
for Bangladesh.
And for that, gradually
there has been some treaties.
And it was so serious that--
let me explain the basics
a little bit first.
So I will be reading from
an article by Saidur Rahman.
So this is the
Ganges water basin.
You can see that, from here, the
Ganges is coming, and coming,
and coming.
And it is entering
from the Hooghly.
Hooghly falls in
the West Bengal.
So previously, before the
partition, Bengal was united.
So there was no East
Bengal or West Bengal.
So after the partition, one
part of Bengal fall into India.
We speak the same language.
Our culture is almost same.
The religion is a
little bit different.
The Hindu majority is in the
western part, the West Bengal.
And the Muslim majority
is in the eastern part.
Because the partition
happened for the two nations
theory, that the Muslims
will be living in Pakistan,
and the Hindus and
other religions
will be living in India.
So that was a theory.
But that didn't work.
So here, when we speak about
this Ganges Water Basin,
we would speak about
the Ganges River.
The Ganges River originates
in the central Himalayas
at the altitude of 7,010
meters, and extends
into the alluvial
and Gangetic plains,
then drains into the Indian
Ocean at the Bay of Bengal.
The Ganges is a
transboundary river,
which has a total length of
approximately 2,600 kilometers
and a total catchment area of
1,087,000 square kilometer.
The river basin spreads
across India, Nepal, China,
and Bangladesh.
Well, India shares the
major portion, which
is 79% of the total basin area.
And in contrast, Bangladesh is
the furthest downstream country
of the basin and
shares only about 4%
of the basin area,
which nevertheless
represents 37% of the
total area of Bangladesh.
The hydrological cycle and water
resources of the Ganges basin
are governed by a
Southwest Monsoon,
characterized by high
temperature, heavy rainfall,
strong seasonal variations.
The region is
characterized by flooding
in the wet season, which
is June to October,
and water scarcity in
the dry season, which
is November to May.
And during the monsoon season,
there is an abundance of water.
But during non-monsoon
season, a lower precipitation
causes a reduced
flow in the basin.
The insufficient supply
of water in the downstream
during the dry season causes
significant socioeconomic
impacts, through disruption
to the agriculture, fisheries,
forestry, and navigation
of this region.
So here, we can see a
little bit more details
of the close-up, the Ganges
River that is entering.
Here is the Farakka Dam.
And there, it's--
Ganges enter Bangladesh through
the West Bengal, the Hooghly
area, Hooghly River.
And it enters and
it becomes Padma,
which is the biggest
river in Bangladesh, also,
which is the economically
most significant river
in Bangladesh.
And the impact, you can
see in the next picture--
you can see that in
the lower part, which
means this part, this
whole part, this Ganges
Delta, the lower part, the
Ganges River, when it enters
Bangladesh, it becomes Padma.
And any change in the flow,
or any climatic change,
or any man-made change
has serious impact
in the lower region of the
southern part of Bangladesh.
And I actually
have seen directly
because my hometown is actually
in the Bagerhat area, which
is in this region.
So although it's like
anecdotal experience,
but I can actually see
that our village area,
it was actually very
full of flora and fauna.
But with time, it
actually reduced.
And now, when I go to the
village after five or 10 years,
we see that it has
totally changed.
So this actually matches
with the academic articles
that I've read here.
So what are the
major water diplomacy
events between Bangladesh
and India since 1971?
As you know that, in 1971,
Bangladesh became independent.
And India had direct help.
India had direct
contribution towards that.
So in 1972, right after
Bangladesh became independent
in 1971, December, and
in 1972, the Bangladesh
father of the nation,
Sheikh Mujibur Rahman,
and Indian prime minister,
Indira Gandhi, they sat down.
Water was actually
an issue back then.
an issue back then
between India and
Pakistan, especially
this Farakka Dam, the Ganges
River water sharing treaty.
So for the first time, they
actually sat down immediately
after the independence
in 1972, which actually
shows that how important
it is for the region
to maintain the peace and
tranquility between the two
countries.
So the first joint
water commission
between India and Bangladesh
was established in 1972.
And this newly-made
joint water commission
between India and Bangladesh
actually tried to survey.
And they try to determine
what are the course of actions
that can be taken.
Because for decades, for
India-Pakistan rivalry,
no development
actually happened.
So in 1974, it was declared
by that commission that--
there was this joint
declaration to resolve
water sharing
issues, the existing
issues that were there.
But in 1975, Bangabandhu,
Sheikh Mujibur Rahman
was killed with his family.
And there was a coup d'état.
And the military took over.
So in 1976, India unilaterally
withdrew from this declaration.
So after this happened,
in 1977, there
was this temporary
five-year treaty,
which ended in 1982, which
started in 1977, giving
the Bangladesh national party
regime, which is historically
considered as anti-India.
So in 1982, it was not renewed.
And after that,
after a long break,
in 1996, there was this treaty
between India and Bangladesh,
which is a Ganges water sharing
treaty between Bangladesh
and India, which
was signed by Deve
Gowda, the then-prime
minister of India
and the present prime minister
of Bangladesh, Sheikh Hasina
Wazed.
So this is more or less
the major developments.
And there is this
interesting fact
that is there, that from
India to Bangladesh,
54 rivers actually come.
And Bangladesh is
in the downstream.
And India is in the upstream.
54 rivers from India--
Bangladesh is a
riverine country.
There is hundreds of rivers.
54 of them actually
comes from India.
And it is spread in Bangladesh
throughout, just like a net.
But unfortunately, so far,
there has been only one treaty,
one proper treaty, which
is the Ganges water
treaty with treaty sharing.
And for last quarter century,
there has been no treaty.
And another water treaty,
the Teesta water treaty,
there has been many talks.
But still, there has
been no development.
So we can actually
understand that why
we are speaking about
this Ganges water sharing
treaty and its significance.
So what do we find
in 1996 water treaty
between Bangladesh and India?
So this was the treaty.
This is the very, very minimum.
That treaty was there.
The sharing calculation
was like this--
70,000 cusecs or less water,
when it's available, 50%
will go to India, 50%
will go to Bangladesh.
If it's between
70,000 to 75,000,
India will maintain the
balance of the flow,
and the Bangladesh will have
remaining a 35,000 cusecs.
And 75,000 or more, when
there is water availability,
40,000 cusecs will go to
India, and Bangladesh will
maintain balance of the flow.
So that was the very basic and
the very minimum of the water
sharing treaty between
Bangladesh and India.
So what are the real scenario?
I mean, this is the
treaty that we have got.
But what is the real scenario?
So here, we can see
the real scenario,
that Bangladesh has
been frequently deprived
of its minimum share during
the most critical periods
of the dry season.
And this has caused the
loss of agricultural land,
created problem in salination.
The wellness of the
people has decreased.
And it has created
such a huge issue,
that in every election
that Bangladesh happens,
this repeatedly comes.
And during the March 21
to 31, the 10-day cycle,
in the year 2010, the
actual release to Bangladesh
was 44% lower than
the indicated release.
And in 2016, the situation
became even worse.
The actual release
during March 21 to 31
was 47% lower than
the indicated share,
followed by a
further 34% and 49%
decrease of flows during the
other alternate political
periods.
So we can see that whatever that
is written there in the treaty,
unfortunately, this is not.
The real scenario is
very, very different,
which is why, I mean, we have
to look into these issues
very seriously.
And we have to decide.
Because this is
going to end in 2025.
This is 2021.
And if it is not renewed,
a very different scenario
might happen.
We don't know what
is going to happen.
But now is actually
the perfect time
to think about this
particular scenario
and think of different
possibilities,
especially from the conflict
resolution point of view.
And what are the problems with
the treaty that we can see?
That it underestimated the
impact of climate variability,
the frequency of
low flow events,
and increased water
restrictions upstream.
And the future climate change
and higher upstream water
demands were not predicted.
And also, in several
locations, neither
Bangladesh-- this
is very interesting.
I was speaking about the problem
that Bangladesh is facing,
but a few articles
actually indicated
that the treaty was
made in such a way that,
in several occasions--
not only once, not only
twice, but several occasions--
neither Bangladesh nor
India was able to receive
their respective shares as
stipulated in the treaty.
And some other problems that
we can discuss with the treaty
is that Bangladesh frequently
did not receive its fair share
during the most critical
periods of the dry season, when
water demand is relatively
high in both countries.
And there was no guarantee
clause for Bangladesh,
which would ensure that--
I mean, although
there is treaty.
But if Bangladesh
does not get, there
is no guarantee that is
ensured for Bangladesh.
So that became
another major problem.
And the opponents of the
current government, they
used to say things like
there is no guarantee, which
means this is just
a show-off, which
also created huge political
turmoil in Bangladesh scenario.
And it is evident that the
advanced hydrological models
were not used, because if
were used, the
prediction would not
be creating so much trouble.
If there was deliberate
error, then maybe one side
would be benefited, and one
side would not be benefited.
But unfortunately, the
standard was set in such a way,
it shows that none of the
countries, several times,
do not get what
they are supposed
to get according to the treaty.
So some of the authors,
like [INAUDIBLE],,
he actually questioned
the hydrological models
that has been used to
deal with the treaty.
And he also claimed that
the advanced models were not
used, which is why the treaty
is in the pen and paper.
But in reality, the quantitative
distribution of water
has not take place properly.
So this is, we
can see, there are
some picture-- two pictures,
actually, that I picked,
what happened during
the dry season.
So Bangladesh is
a country, which
used to be full of blessings
from the nature, a lot of--
I mean, you wouldn't see
dry lands very often.
But after this barrage
actually happened
and during the dry season,
this actually happened.
And what happened is the poor
farmers, I mean, many of them
actually lost their lands.
And they had to--
I mean, some of them
actually-- there
has been cases that some of
them could not even survive.
Physically, they
couldn't survive.
And many of them in those
areas, they left their lands.
And they came to
the capital city,
which is why, after they
came to the capital city,
they didn't do anything
but agriculture.
But they started to find a job.
They didn't find it.
So they tried to do other
things, which didn't work.
And at one point, what
happened that crime rate
increased very high.
Because these people, they
cannot survive in their area.
And they come to the capital
city or the big cities.
And they start a
career in crime.
So that is how actually,
indirectly, even with the crime
perspective, even the law
enforcement perspective,
this Farakka is actually
affecting Bangladesh.
So let's see the
ground realities.
So now that we will
enter into the third part
of our presentation, which
is the water diplomacy part.
So let us check out some
of the ground realities.
First of all, I mean, India
has economic, political,
geographical, and
military advantage.
And not only that, it
has been very few--
I mean, for last
almost 15 years,
the present government
is in power.
And they have very
strong tie with Indians.
And many of the
political experts,
they say that without
India's support and backing,
this government wouldn't
probably survive.
So some of the
political scientists,
they actually come up with
that sort of analysis.
So I mean, whether
this is true or false,
that is a separate issue.
But one thing that is clear,
that a huge, huge population,
a major population group,
they actually believe this.
And once they believe
this, they automatically
have the anti-India sentiment.
And India, by cashing out
on this sentiment, even
the political leaders,
they also get paranoid.
They also think that if we
try to take any decision that
does not directly go
in favor of India,
maybe India will try to pressure
the Bangladesh politics,
and the Bangladeshi political
leaders will lose their seat.
So with this fear, very,
very little instance
up there that Bangladesh
actually confronted India.
And I'm sure that
this situation is not
uncommon in other
parts of the world.
So also, like in 1971,
India was directly
supporting Bangladesh
to become independent.
Their soldiers actually died
with our freedom fighters.
So what happened that
when the war ended,
immediately, there was a
joint commission initiated.
But it is very
unlikely that that sort
of warmth of relationship
between the two countries
is going to come back
in the near future.
And even there is a
strong political will,
there is animosity, both
from Bangladesh side
and the Indian side.
And as I say that there is very
strong anti-Indian sentiment
currently living in Bangladesh.
And these feelings is mutual
due to the political scenario
both in India and in Bangladesh.
The present government
in India, they try to--
they are a populist government.
And there is us versus
them-- this sentiment
is being very much played in
India, and also in Bangladesh.
So these are the
ground realities.
So what are the
things that we can
do that I'm trying to portray?
The first water diplomacy
approach that I try to find
is finding common grounds.
What are the common
grounds that we can say?
Because Bangladesh
actually stand no chance
by confronting India, saying
that you have to give us.
India will just say that
well, we won't give you.
Do whatever you want.
So here, this International
Water Management Institute.
So from there, I
actually brought this.
And so these are the
issues that we can see,
that low-dry season freshwater
flow, the increasing siltation,
accumulation of
sediments, water resources
along the areas of the
river basins are depleting.
The small rivers
and the distributor
is getting dried and
disconnected, reduced length
of waterways used for
links and navigation,
and riverbed erosion,
formation of dry lands,
and the socioeconomic
vulnerabilities.
So the problems that
has been there--
Goral is actually a variant
of the Ganges River,
on the middle side
of the Bangladesh.
And Hooghly-Bhagirathi
River is in the West Bengal,
another river.
So these common issues
that is actually there
both between India
and Bangladesh.
So the joint water
commission that we have,
and in our water
diplomacy syllabus,
what we have studied
in various times,
that an emphasis on joint
protocol and finding
the common ground, and
finding the common challenges
is very much stressed
in water diplomacy.
So I think these
are the issues that
happens both for
India and Bangladesh
during the dry seasons in
West Bengal and in Bangladesh.
So these are the things that
both the parties can discuss.
And they can try to share
some common ground, which
can be exploited.
And that is how the
treaty can be upgraded.
So another modern
diplomacy approach
is indicating India's own
problems with Farakka.
This is a 2017 newspaper
article with some references.
So there is this
Indian chief engineer.
He actually discussed when this
plan was happening in 1961.
So he actually pointed
out some various problems,
for example, the drought
and the climate change.
These are the things
he actually pointed out
to the Indian government.
He's a Bengali guy,
Krishna Bhattacharya.
So he actually pointed
out those problems.
But back then, his career took--
he was a chief engineer
on the West Bengal side
when this Farakka
Dam was happening.
And when he indicated
those problems,
for example, the
different parts of Patna
into and for other districts
in Bihar, the flooding,
the drought, and the
change of biodiversity,
and the salinity issues.
And also, the annual silt
dredging in Kolkata port
quadrupled from 6.4 million
cubic meter to 21.88 million
cubic meter till 2003.
So this sort of things happened.
And these were
actually predicted.
So this problem, not only
it's from an academic report.
This was so serious that
Bihar, in the Bihar area,
some very influential
politicians--
the chief ministers--
and they actually
say the central government
that why don't you, I mean,
demolish the Farakka Dam?
So the way Bangladesh wants
a solution for this Farakka
problem, even some
parts of India
there actually wants the same.
So when there would be
a discussion, maybe,
from Bangladesh's perspective,
this India's own interest
can be exploited and
come to a middle ground.
And this is something
which Bangladesh repeatedly
failed at, India became
repeatedly successful.
Bangladesh, after the
1982, when another party,
which is historically
considered as anti-India,
they came to power, they tried
to internationalize the Farakka
situation.
They tried to--
I mean, the SAARC was built.
And then this issue was taken.
But India was actually stressing
that this is a bilateral issue.
But if you look
at the basin, you
will see that there is China,
Bhutan, Nepal, and Bangladesh.
Well, Bhutan and
Nepal, their case
is exactly like Bangladesh.
But the surprising
new scenario is
that, now that China has
global aspirations, China more
than once, they came out
with the Teesta river--
which is another river in the
northern part of Bangladesh.
They came up with the proposal
that we would help you
with the technology
and the money
so that you can build another
bridge on another side.
So this became another
bargaining chip for Bangladesh,
that using the China factor
and building an international--
the Joint Commission
can be international.
It needs not to be bilateral.
It can be international,
bringing China,
since China is actually
trying to provide Bangladesh
with some new options.
And they are actually saying
that China's water weapon, that
is the word they have used.
But this is a concept that I've
borrowed from the [INAUDIBLE]
class.
They're bringing
other bargaining chips
that is not usually considered.
For example, this is Bangladesh.
On the left side, the
West Bengal is there.
You can see the
Jharkhand, Bihar.
And this is Nepal, Bhutan.
This is Bangladesh.
And you see a huge part of
India is actually there.
And the majority of the
border is with Bangladesh.
And there is, I
mean, sentiment--
there is strong sentiment
against the central Indian
government, because
it is very much--
I mean, it is called
the Seven Sisters.
And the Seven
Sisters, well, this
is far from the central
government, which is
why the control is very much--
I mean, not as strong as
Delhi or the nearby states.
And many of these states, they
actually want independence
of their own, which
is why, even when,
at present, Bangladesh and India
has a very strong tie because
of the historical reasons.
The present prime minister,
when his whole family
was killed, for six
years, he actually
lived under the
Indian protection.
So it is considered that
she would probably never go
against the interests of India.
But when anti-Indian
sentiment comes
with a new political
party, there
is always threat that
this part of India
would be very much tumultuous.
There will be terrorism.
And many of the
terrorist leaders,
many of the nationalist
leaders of those parties,
they actually--
I mean, they used to
operate from Bangladesh.
And one famous
incident that I can
say that in 2004, a
10-truck load of most
advanced military weapons were
passing towards Bangladesh.
But it was a fluke
that it was caught.
So it became a huge case.
So I mean, it can be a
huge trouble for India.
So this particular
issue can actually
be brought in the
negotiation table,
by saying that well,
we will provide you
full support with
safety and security
of the Seven Sister's part.
In exchange, maybe we can
discuss about the sharing
of the water treaty.
So this is one bargaining chip,
which I think can be exploited.
I try to check the literature.
But so far, I haven't
seen that Bangladesh
has went through that path.
And another chip can be--
there are some articles
from the Indian sides.
They actually claim
that the Bengal--
Bengal means the West Bengal--
they need Teesta.
And the Teesta, we have
a barrage in Teesta.
We have a dam in Teesta.
And still, there
has been many talks.
But so far, there
has been no treaty.
So I mean, although
we are speaking
about the advancement
of Ganges treaty,
double relations Ganges
treaty, maybe the Teesta River,
to get some advantage
in Ganges river treaty,
Bangladesh actually can think
of discussing with India
whether they can bring
this Teesta river
treaty with them as well.
Teesta is very sensitive,
because Teesta is actually--
it has originated in Sikkim,
which is very close to China.
And this is the Teesta
River, especially
for which the Chinese
actually offered Bangladesh
technical support to bring for
the dams, and by doing that,
changing the course
of the river.
So it became a
very serious issue
between Bangladesh and India.
And the diplomatic talks
are still going on.
So these are actually
the steps that we
can think of using as
the bargaining chip
so that a new joint
commission can be made.
And the things like climate
change and the other problems,
which was not considered in
1996, can be considered now.
Because in almost 30 years,
the technology has changed,
the GPS has come,
and many other--
the scientific
scenario has changed.
So maybe, by bringing all
these things together,
a better solution can be saved.
And before I finish
with all the criticisms,
I would actually
again say that--
which I did feel and I also read
from the [INAUDIBLE] article,
that this Ganges water
treaty is probably--
it is not perfect.
It is definitely not perfect.
But if it was not
there, the situation
for both the countries
would probably worse.
So the treaty should be there.
And we should try our best to--
we have four years.
Maybe we can try
our best to think
of the advancement
of that treaty
and also addressing
the limitations
that we are currently facing.
Thank you very much.
If you have any comments and
if you have any questions,
I would like to answer them.
Thank you very much.
DR. GAIN: Thank you, Mashroof,
for the nice presentation.
So now, I would like to ask
others to make comments,
like Aaron and Gemma.
Do you have any
comments or feedback?
AUDIENCE: Thank you,
Mashroof, for a really great
presentation.
I learned a lot.
I really appreciated how much
geographic and geopolitical
context you brought in.
I thought that was
really helpful.
And I really liked
the back third
of your presentation,
where you really
kind of thought through all of
the water diplomacy framework
elements.
So yeah, great job.
I think my feedback, as
you're thinking about writing
your paper, would be--
I was a little confused at times
about how the treaty has failed
to be implemented, thinking
about most specifically around
how neither country
is able to receive
their respective share as it
was stipulated in the treaty.
Is that a technical problem?
Is that a diplomatic problem?
I think you could maybe identify
where the specific limitations
or weaknesses of the
treaty are and in terms
of how that actually is
manifested on the ground.
So that's one thing
to keep in mind.
Yeah, I don't know if you
could talk about that at all.
Are there technical flaws
or political flaws that
might be helpful to understand?
MASHROOF HOSSAIN: Well,
the technical flaws--
I actually accept
my limitations.
I'm not really a technical guy.
I try to read some
technical papers.
I actually read one of
Professor Animesh's paper,
which gave me some insight.
So the one technical
paper that I read,
they say that in
last two decades,
almost last two decades, very
few papers or very few research
has been done to actually trying
to quantify the amount of water
that has been there.
One of the reasons was
there that initially,
the historical data was
not there, for example,
in first five years, probably--
I mean, first one or two years--
the type of precision
that you need
to get to predict
that what is going
to happen through the history.
Now that we have
it, fortunately,
because it has been quite long,
so the research has already
started.
So maybe I will try to put that.
And the diplomatic problems
that we are say that--
one major problem that I can
say, I mean, since this is--
I would never say this
outside the classroom--
that for example, US, it
has a national policy.
The government changes, but
the policy, the main theme
of the policy, remains.
Maybe some sides
changes, but if you
have to change the main theme
of the policy-- for example,
US has a defense policy.
Right, US has a defense
policy that we will do this,
we will do that.
How will we do that, maybe
that can be discussed.
And maybe different governments
can do it in a different way.
So in India, of course,
Indian democracy
is not as strong as
the US or the UK.
But in India, in some
basic sectors, for example,
the defense or whether they
would share this or that,
they also have some
sort of policy.
They also have some
sort of strict policy
that even though the
political government changes,
this doesn't change much.
And they strongly
uphold the Constitution.
And one of the reasons
is that there has not
been, in the history of
India, more than 60 years--
from '47 to 2021,
more than 60 years--
no military takeover was there.
And because India is so
huge, military takeover
is actually not
very much feasible.
But in Bangladesh, it's a
country 50 years of age.
Out of 50 years, more
than 15 years there
were military governments.
And I would be very
blunt here at present.
We are also have some
autocratic government.
And the system has
become such that, I mean,
it is very tough for
Bangladesh to come out
from this political.
So when you speak
of diplomacy, we
have some wonderful diplomats,
really well-trained diplomats.
But the decision actually
comes from the politicians.
I would not blame them.
They definitely have
their point of view.
But due to this lack
of political culture,
of having a straight
aim, I mean--
it is like, I mean, total
one government comes,
so for the five or 10
years, one policy was going.
The government changes,
it goes backwards.
So it's zig-zag, zig-zag.
So I mean, it is an issue.
But thank you very much for
the input, because I will
try to address these things.
Specifically, maybe I
wouldn't be speaking too much
about diplomacy, because
I work for the government.
And they read those papers.
But the technical part,
maybe I will seek help
from Larry and Professor
Gain to include
more of the technical
parts in my paper.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Mashroof,
also I learned a huge amount
in your presentation.
The question I have--
and perhaps you
addressed this somewhat-- but I
would like to speak more to it.
Maybe I missed it, but does
the current treaty have--
how does it manage
water measurement?
And in the processes
for actually determining
how much water there is
different times of year
and how much water
there is over time--
because you talked
about the ways
in which the amount
of water has changed,
partially as a
result of droughts
and the different pieces
of infrastructure that
have been built.
But I'm interested in if there's
any ongoing collaboration,
or shared effort, or
even individual kind
of national efforts to quantify
how the water, both quantity
and quality, is
changing over time.
MASHROOF HOSSAIN: Well, I
do not know very details
of the technicalities.
But I can give you
some very basics,
which is there on the treaty.
So the geography
of the two regions
is more or less the same, the
West Bengal and Bangladesh.
So although we are
speaking of India,
India is a very big country,
right, so 28 states.
But ultimately, Bangladesh
shares with West Bengal,
from where the
Ganges River comes.
So I mean, by
studying Bangladesh
or by studying West
Bengal, a very basic idea
actually can be found.
For example, the dry
season in Bangladesh,
from January to May, it
is same in West Bengal.
And the wet season
in Bangladesh,
which falls up to December,
so from July to December, that
is also same in
both the parties.
So the joint committee,
they probably
used some hydraulic
models to actually set
the amount of water.
For example, it is 70,000
cubics, the basic standard.
The first one is if there
is 70,000 cubic seconds--
the unit is cusec-- if
70,000 cusecs is there,
both the countries
will share 50-50%.
So this is how they have made.
And from 70% to 75%,
so there would be--
the balanced ratio
would be for India.
And Bangladesh would get
a minimum 34,000 cusecs.
And if it's 75 to--
75 and above, then the same
kind of ratio is there.
So this much I know.
AUDIENCE: Is there ongoing--
for example, you
mentioned that there
have been years in which neither
side has gotten the amounts
that they've been allocated.
Have there been
any ongoing efforts
to know, if there's
under 70,000,
to quantify how much is flowing?
And how?
MASHROOF HOSSAIN: Yes.
I think that Bangladesh,
we have an agency--
Bangladesh Inland
Water Authority--
we have Bangladesh
Water Development Board.
So they actually conduct
some scientific studies.
And based on those, I
will be honest with you
that the government
organizations--
I mean, for example,
the scientists
who have that expertise,
the Bangladesh--
those organizations are not
really the most lucrative jobs
for them.
So we do what we can.
And sometimes, we bring
foreign consultants.
And with those, some
studies are made.
And based on that, actually,
these sort of distributions
are made.
But then again, there
are flaws in this study.
DR. GAIN: Mashroof, I think
in terms of measurement,
the joint river commission is--
so there is joint collaboration
between India and Bangladesh.
The Joint River Commission
is responsible for measuring
the things.
So in terms of theory,
both the Indian side,
there is a Joint
River Commission.
And in the Bangladesh
side, there
is Joint River Commission.
So both parties,
in terms of theory,
theoretically, they measure.
And in terms of dry season
river, they measure the flow.
And they agree on that.
So I think in
terms of agreement,
they do have these
kind of things.
But in reality, this
kind of collaboration,
although that exists, but this
kind of enforcement is-- they
rely only on the Indian side,
that maybe they don't regularly
go to the Farakka point
to measure the things.
But I think the way that
Indian Joint River Commission
communicate to the
Bangladesh Joint Commission,
they agree on that
kind of measurement.
So that's the idea.
MASHROOF HOSSAIN: I was actually
looking for some articles
whether the state
water department--
I'm not sure that whether
the Indian states have
separate water departments or
not, or whether it's federal.
I'm not sure.
So I'll try to
find whether there
is any collaboration between
not only the state level,
but also the--
not only the federal level,
but also the West Bengal
state and Bangladesh.
But probably, I probably missed.
I didn't find any
such collaboration.
DR. GAIN: So is there
any other feedback
that you would like to bring,
like Anselmo or Hasnain?
AUDIENCE: Mashroof,
congratulation
on the presentation.
I learned a lot from you today.
MASHROOF HOSSAIN:
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Especially the
visual was very rich,
your presentation.
I just have one
quick suggestion,
because you said
that you are not
going to mention a lot
about the diplomacy
because you are part
of the government.
But when you read
the Larry's book,
on the-- specific
on the page 133,
it mentions about the water
management in the state
hold the key approach
to the conflict,
using the traditional way.
Or they can use the
non-zero-sum approach.
And I think that's very
interesting, if you can
include in your final paper.
MASHROOF HOSSAIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Specific when
they talk about the water
management, that's fall in
two categories-- a higher
authority can force a
decision, or the other parties
themselves can negotiate a
settlement that formal talks
helped to implement.
I think this chapter
is very interesting
for your presentation.
MASHROOF HOSSAIN:
Thank you very much.
I will look into that and I
will try to incorporate it.
AUDIENCE: It's on page 132, 133.
MASHROOF HOSSAIN:
Thank you very much.
DR. GAIN: Yes.
Yeah, Larry?
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Thanks
for the presentation.
I'm hoping that you can
synthesize the diplomacy
discussion in the final
version of the paper.
And it would be wonderful if
you had a one-page introduction
to your discussion about
diplomacy that highlighted
two or three ideas about what
new or different, with regard
to diplomacy, that could be
tried that hasn't been tried,
without going into
all the explanation
in this summary of how
this would be done,
but to just highlight.
You talking about
bargaining chips,
you're talking about linking
other issues, it's a lot.
Pick two or three
things that you
want to suggest that are new.
And say, I think
the focus should
shift to involving
all of the states
and not just the
national governments.
OK?
If that's one of
your proposals, then
state that as a
new emphasis that
might change the whole story.
If you think, as
Aaron was implying,
that a new approach
to joint measurement
would provide timely and
believable information
in a different way, and
that with that information,
new joint management,
under different sets
of circumstances, would be
improved even if the treaty
isn't changed, then say that.
But not more than
two or three ideas
that could be expressed
in a couple of sentences
as the contribution to your
discussion about diplomacy.
Because otherwise,
it's too much.
It's impossible to follow
all the different lines
of diplomacy that are implied
by the different maps,
and the different
bargaining chips,
and the different relationships,
and what might be done.
And it's just too much.
Just choose two, no more than
three, but even those two ideas
about changed diplomacy
and highlight those, OK?
I know that you have
lots of other stuff.
I think for the paper,
the power of the paper
will be improved if you
zero in on just a couple
of ideas about changes in the
diplomacy going forward that
haven't been given enough or
the right attention in the past.
MASHROOF HOSSAIN:
Professor, in that case,
maybe I will try to speak
about the one point that I say.
Maybe instead of three or
two, I will just focus on one.
That is the bargaining chips,
the alternate bargaining chips.
Maybe I can choose just this
one and go deeper on that.
What do you think?
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: I think that
there are different bargaining
chips that are more or
less attractive to one
country or another.
And that instead of saying
bargaining chips is one thing--
MASHROOF HOSSAIN: I would
specify the bargaining chip.
Pick one bargaining chip
and go deeper on that.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Which ones?
I mean, I thought the idea
that you have all these states,
they're not happy with their
own national government,
it's possible that a negotiation
involving those states
could change what
gets talked about,
and shift the balance
of power, and provide
an opportunity for sub-regional
piece of the treaty
to go ahead.
So that's about
bargaining chips.
But it's about the involvement
of sub-national units
on the India side and
why their involvement
could make a difference.
So I'm really saying,
don't just talk
about things at the level
of bargaining chips.
It's too broad.
MASHROOF HOSSAIN: Pick.
AUDIENCE: Pick a couple of
bargaining chips that you think
are most promising and
say who should do what
with this new
bargaining chip that
might lead to
either a new treaty,
or better administration
of the existing treaty,
or a completely
different kind of treaty.
I mean, not-- keep
the one you have.
And in addition, adopt
maybe a new treaty
about this additional river.
Maybe that's what opens things.
But take specific
bargaining chips
and make them into
your recommendations.
OK?
MASHROOF HOSSAIN: OK, professor.
Thank you.
DR. GAIN: Yeah, so in line
with Larry's suggestion,
so my suggestion would be--
so you mentioned only the
state versus state diplomacy.
But you know, the India's
water resource responsibility
is given to the state--
I mean, not federal state.
So more most of the water
power is given to the state--
I mean, West Bengal state has
the power for managing water
resources in the West Bengal.
So the central government cannot
intervene anything regarding
the decision of the West
Bengal's water resources
issues.
So in that case, one
of the key stakeholders
would be the West Bengal.
And I mean, how the
Teesta water treaty
didn't work although the
central government was--
MASHROOF HOSSAIN: Agreed.
DR. GAIN: --agreed with
the Bangladesh government.
But because of the West Bengal
government, it didn't happen.
So I think this, as Larry
mentioned, we can incorporate,
or you can incorporate
the state as stakeholders.
Maybe that can also important.
And I think that is
essential, not important,
because without the state,
you cannot negotiate with
the central government.
So this is on point.
And in terms of
identifying issues,
already, if you ask some of
the peoples, key peoples,
then it would be easier for you.
So you already identified
several key issues.
One of the issues is Bangladesh
is concerned regarding
the climate change and its
impact on the future river
flow.
And so this is one
of the key aspects.
But also, other aspect
for the [INAUDIBLE],,
you already mentioned
incorporating how the Seven
Sisters and the transit
Bangladesh can help achieving
this--
the new water treaty
that incorporates
ensuring future river flow.
But also, the last
few years, there
was a discussion for developing
barrage in the Ganges
within the Bangladesh
part, which India denied
and which India opposed.
And that plan has been halt.
MASHROOF HOSSAIN:
The deep sea base.
DR. GAIN: Not deep
sea, barrage in the--
MASHROOF HOSSAIN: Oh,
the barrage, yeah.
DR. GAIN: Yeah, the
freshwater flow barrage
in the Bangladesh to a store
freshwater for southwest part
of the Bangladesh.
So this kind of
option creation can
be helpful for
treaty negotiations.
So I believe, if you can
ask some of the peoples
that I already mentioned to
you, if you interview them,
I think you can have much
more insight for the paper.
You might not consider
them, given the time limit.
But as Larry mentioned,
if you consider
only two or three
specific points that
can be helpful for
incorporating-- so one
could be the climate change.
Other could be the engaging
stakeholders, like state-level
stakeholders and interacting
with the Seven Sisters
state for the
transit and how this
can help treaty negotiations.
These are specific
aspects you can consider.
MASHROOF HOSSAIN:
Thank you very much.